it's a delayed response but a massive
one international efforts to evacuate
are at their Peak and people here
welcome this golden ticket
this is just incredible and completely
unprecedented a U.S naval Rescue Mission
with the support of a UK War vessel and
the partnership of the Sydney's military
and the police to get people across the
Red Sea away from Sudan to safety the
first drops of international Aid has
finally trickled in along with rows of
un Hardware the United Nations has come
under Fire for its slow crisis response
and a transition mission that has thus
far failed to Herald peace
in an exclusive TV interview the UN
special representative to Sudan answers
some pressing questions
did you see this coming we saw enormous
tensions between the South leadership
and the rsf leadership and we struggled
particularly in the last two weeks
before 15 April before the outbreak of
hostilities but of course we did not see
it coming Saturday morning
millions are now internally displaced
and at least 50 000 have fled the
country with such a dramatic escalation
many wonder why the UN did not send
supplies sooner
why has it taken so long for
humanitarian Aid to arrive to Sudan
because
so many of the humanitarian Aid which we
had in stock was looted
all the warehouses wfp
unhcr and others in therefore were
looted vehicles from the humanitarian
agencies were looted as the offices of
my own mission uni terms as well as
obviously agencies in most of the towns
afterwards were looted
another ceasefire has been extended but
in the streets of the capital they
rarely hold
none of the ceasefires has been
respected in taupo they have all been
respected partially and sometimes only
in some locations and not in others
it's this untameable chaos that people
are crossing the Seas to leave behind
people relieved yeah
[Music]
yeah before you can
do
it
and we appreciate
everybody you know I'm saying chipping
in helping out yeah so
I just hope it ends soon so everybody
else can get out
devastating two weeks but an
inspirational time too an example of how
coming together in a crisis is the only
way through
Sky News Port Sudan